[Música]
tampoco muy lenta ahora porque el 60% de
los niños de sexto grado de primaria no
alcanza niveles mínimos de lectura y
matemáticas según el último informe
revelado por la UNESCO la educación en
nuestra región en América Latina no
registraba haces destacables desde el
año 2013 la Oficina Regional de
Educación para América Latina y el
Caribe insto entonces a los gobiernos y
sistemas educacionales a intensificar
los esfuerzos para mejorar el
aprendizaje de los estudiantes y hacer
efectivo el derecho a una educación de
calidad y es que incluso un año antes de
la pandemia covid-19 más del 40% de los
estudiantes de tercer grado no
alcanzaban el nivel mínimo de
competencia fundamentales en lecturas y
también de matemáticas los datos salen
de un estudio regional realizado a más
de 160000 niños de 16 países y para ello
quiero dar la bienvenida a nuestro
segundo invitado Carlos Enrique score de
laboratorio Latinoamericano de
evaluación de la calidad de la educación
de la UNESCO gracias por atendernos
Carlos y estar con nosotros en directo
América de France 24 lamentable las
igualdad en nuestra región que pasa con
la educación de nuestros niños
así es la educación en América Latina y
el Caribe claramente está en riesgo pese
a los tremendos esfuerzos que se han
estado realizando por cada uno de los
gobiernos cuatro de cada diez niños se
encuentra en el nivel más va qué quiere
decir esto no logran poder localizar
información en textos con información
destacable estamos hablando de
habilidades mentales fundamentales para
el desarrollo actual del niño para que
pueda ser competente en su contexto y
poder desarrollarse lo mismo sucede en
matemáticas son estudiantes que no
lograron finalmente poder hacer
operaciones
sumar restar o realizar alguna
[Música]
ejercer el derecho aprender a
relacionarse con su entorno por eso
desde desde la UNESCO desde laboratorio
Latinoamericano de evaluación de la
calidad de la educación desde el
jesenest esfuerzo con los 16 países
creemos que esta información es
imprescindible de ser utilizada para la
mejora ya que como tú decías la pandemia
incluso viene a extremar finalmente
estas inequidades
informaciones fue los meses anteriores
al comienzo de la pandemia cómo podemos
abordar este problema estamos condenados
siempre a tener este tipo de
problemáticas que evidentemente no son
nuevas en nuestra región
[Música]
la región no tiene avance sustantivo
entre el 2013 y el 2019 pero si hay
países que logran mejora sustantiva con
su estudiar por tanto información nos
permite salero tu pregunta tres
elementos necesitamos invertir más en
educación países que invierten más
permiten poder compensar en equidad y
profunda los sistemas educativos s
imperfil mejor que quiere decir esto
utilizar de buena manera los recursos
focalizar los grupos que más se quedan
atrás y tercero que creemos que una
información muy relevante en este
estudio ese para 16 países miembros
laboratorio
prácticas docentes logran mejores
resultados en el bienestar y aprendizaje
su estudiante qué quiere decir estos son
capaces de mejorar la enseñanza y
centrarse en los procesos cognitivos
cuánto tiene mi interés por el bienestar
cuando organizan las clases cuando su
preocupación está por generar instancias
de aprendizaje los estudiantes aprenden
más por tanto lo que hace el maestro no
da lo mismo lo que hacen maestro y la
maestra sin marca la diferencia y te
insisto no estamos condenados pero si
requieres en la sociedad latinoamericana
en su conjunto y el Caribe pueda tomar
esta información para mejorar las
políticas públicas que vienen y si tomas
una en el contexto de complicaciones es
el contexto para yo preguntarle sobre
otro tema que quería abordar y es la
corrupción que vivimos en nuestro país
en América Latina y también los muy
bajos salarios de nuestros maestros
nuestros profesores eso también no sería
parte el problema como incentivar más a
los educadores para que tenga nuestros
niños entonces una educación de calidad
en el centro de lo que puede movilizar
mayores aprendizaje y el derecho a la
educación en nuestras niñas y niños
buenos profesores buenos estudiantes
tribuir a mejores docentes a los
docentes que vivían están en nuestra
región por tanto hay que mirarlas buena
experiencia en todos los países hay
colegio que están mejorando hay que
aprender de ellos y te insisto dudas en
el centro neurálgico de la construcción
de mejora como los docentes los
valoramos como los docentes los atraemos
y como a los docentes retribuimos para
que el techo el sistema educativo ellos
no ayudan a movilizar y en definitiva
generar mejores oportunidades de
aprendizaje y nuestras niñas y en
nuestros niños Carlos muy brevemente
está esta falencia de nuestros niños en
nuestra en nuestra región América Latina
y Caribe cómo afecta en un futuro
digamos a las competencias mundiales
para los trabajos internacionales bien
remunerados con respecto a unos países
más desarrollados de la educación pues
lamentablemente superior a la nuestro
país
lo que has estado hablando en el mundo
Fuenlabrada del siglo 21 para poder
optar a lo que tiene que ver con mejores
remuneraciones mejores trabajos y
también lo comentamos de la UNESCO como
los cada ciudadano aporta su desarrollo
individual social y colectivo eso es
indispensable pero nuestros niños
nuestros hijos hija nietos sobrinos no
van a poder participar de este mundo de
cooperación de trabajo en equipo de
pensamiento crítico si no cuentan con
las habilidades fundamentales como saber
leer la operaciones básicas lectura o un
pensamiento matemático o científico por
eso es indispensable un niño que no
cuenta con este tipo